-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back to the attic.
If you have been following
my three-months-plus journey
up here, you know we've had
to work out some kinks.
There have been book shenanigans
and infestation
of adorable wasps,
my hair part mysteriously
switching sides.
And then, on top of all that,
some helpful eagle-eyed viewers
caught a bit of an irregularity
from our Monday show,
something that can
only be described
as an accidental cameo.
I assure you we are looking
into this problem
and we will have it fixed.
As I have repeatedly
told my many famous friends,
the door in my attic,
regardless
of its apparent
magical qualities,
is not to be abused
for walk-ons or plugs,
and I certainly don't
wanna be responsible
for anyone gettin'
trapped in there,
especially not Academy Award
nominee Ethan Hawke.
Because, you know,
that man commits.
If he gets trapped in there,
it's gonna be like 12 years,
"Boyhood"-style.
And, speaking of things
that feel like
they've gone on for 12 years,
President Trump --
yes, the segues are back! --
and his allies on Fox News
have settled
on a strategy
for getting reelected.
Economic reco--
Oh, sorry. I read that wrong.
Racism!
Their strategy is racism.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
Every day brings
fresh new evidence
of the depravity
and amoral criminality
of the Trump administration.
The details may differ,
but, in many ways,
it feels like the same day
over and over again.
It's like we're all Bill Murray
in "Groundhog Day,"
except no one
is learning the piano
and we still hate Ned Ryerson.
Get lost, Ned!
This is "Groundhog Day,"
if the ceremony was waiting
for the groundhog to make
his way down the ramp.
No matter what, it takes him
six more weeks of winter
to get from the top
to the bottom.
Congress could spend
the next decade
investigating Trump and still
not get to everything.
He's a racist tax cheat
who profits from his office,
wants to slow down testing
for a pandemic he ignored,
he's facing new accusations
that he extorted
multiple countries
to interfere in our elections
and, just today, we heard
damning congressional testimony
from a prosecutor
in the Roger Stone case,
alleging that top
Justice Department officials
intervened to get favorable
treatment for Stone
because he was a political
ally of the president.
-At a House Judiciary Committee
hearing later today,
a federal prosecutor plans
to testify
that Attorney General
William Barr
and his top deputies gave
inappropriate orders on cases
in an effort to cater
to President Trump.
-Roger Stone was treated
differently because of politics.
What I heard, repeatedly,
was that this leniency
was happening
because of Stone's
relationship to the president,
that the acting U.S. attorney
for the District of Columbia
was receiving heavy pressure
from the highest levels
of the Department of Justice
and that his instructions to us
were based on political
considerations.
And I was told
that the acting U.S. attorney
was giving Stone a break
because he was afraid
of the president
of the United States.
-Of course they're afraid
of the president.
Look at him.
Looks like something
from a legend they tell kids
in a small Irish village
to make them do
their homework.
[ Irish accent ]
Finish your maths, Liam,
or the fire gollum
will climb into the window
and eat your hands.
He'll eat your hands, Liam!
Looks like something
that would pop out at you
on a Amazon River cruise.
Anaconman.
Whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
That one deserves
an attic high-five.
-[ Electronic voice ]
-[ Clap ]
The president subverted
the rule of law
to get favorable treatment
for a political ally
and key go-between
in Russia's criminal conspiracy
to help Trump
win the 2016 election.
A guy who, setting aside
all the evidence against him,
looks like an obvious criminal.
I mean, he just looks
like a villain
who would try to steal
the TARDIS from Doctor Who.
If you didn't know he was
an adviser to Trump,
you'd think he was
a Times Square weirdo,
pretending to be James Spader
from "The Blacklist."
[ As Red ]
Hey, lady, your kids
want a picture with Red?
You know, Red
from "The Blacklist."
And, hey, since we
mentioned James Spader,
I also want to mention
that my summer goal
continues to be
growing my hair long enough
to look like
James Spader's character, Steff,
from "Pretty in Pink."
I'm gonna go out and buy
the suit and everything.
Of course, the only thing
I can't buy
is that Spader confidence.
Ah, one day.
And the Stone news comes
just days after Trump's DOJ
ousted one of the most powerful
prosecutors in the country,
the U.S. attorney for the
Southern District New York.
That's the office
currently overseeing
several investigations
of Trump and his allies,
including Trump's lawyer
and sundowning gremlin
Rudy Giuliani.
[ Irish accent ]
Finish your science project,
too, Liam,
or the potato vampire
will fly through your window
and steal your pills.
I don't know what he wants
your pills for, Liam.
I just know he's comin',
If that papier-mâché volcano
isn't done come mornin',
Liam!
Trump is using the cover
of a series
of acute national crises,
from institutional racism
and police brutality
to the pandemic,
to the economic crash,
to dismantle the rule of law
and protect himself
and his cronies.
It's like if Nixon had managed
to distract everyone
from Watergate
by crashin' his car
into a Dairy Queen.
There are days
when it can feel difficult
to fully capture the gravity
of the situation we're in,
but then, there are other
days, when you realize
there really are no words
to convey just how seismically,
historically,
earth-shatteringly stupid
everything is right now.
Like yesterday,
when the president spoke
to an auditorium
of so-called Students for Trump
in a state, Arizona,
which is currently seeing
a record-setting spike
in coronavirus cases,
and he amped up the crowd
with this super racist comment.
-There's never been anything
where they have so many names.
I could give you 19 or 20
names for that, right?
It's got all different names.
Wuhan.
[ Laughter ]
Wuhan was catching on.
Coronavirus, right?
[ Shouting ]
Kung flu, yes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Kung flu [ Indistinct ]
Kung flu.
-You know,
racists like to complain
that the rules are changing
all the time
and they don't know what's
okay to say, what isn't,
but that would've been
racist in 1920.
If Clara Bow had said that,
she'd have been canceled.
"Bow's Gotta Go!"
That's like something
a racist fourth grader
would spray-paint
in the bathroom
and get expelled for,
unless that school required
two-thirds of the Senate
to vote to expel,
in which case,
Susan Collins
would be telling us...
[ As Collins ]
I think Timmy
has learned his lesson,
in regards to spray-painting.
Sssss!
He's spray-painting behind me
right now, isn't he?
I don't know what to say
anymore, man.
He just sucks, so hard.
Just a thoroughly cretinous,
irredeemable Mr. Tomato Head,
slinkin' back to the White House
like he just got kicked
out of a party at Studio 54
for doin' whippets
in the bathroom.
He has to be the biggest
douche on Earth,
and I say that knowing full well
that Kid Rock is out there,
somewhere, fillin' up
a pair of flag pants
with chili dog farts.
It's especially
disheartening to hear
the audience losing their minds,
like Gallagher just walked out
with a watermelon.
Now, the audience was supposed
to be Students for Trump
and I'm just guessing,
but the word students
and Students for Trump
probably has a pretty
a loose definition.
They're probably students
the way Trump is, you know,
"married."
But don't worry.
Trump made sure to follow up
his trademark racism
with some breathtaking
stupidity, too.
-COVID, COVID-19, COVID.
I say, "What's the 19?
COVID-19."
Some people can't explain
what the 19.
COVID-19.
I said, "That's an odd name."
-What do you think it means?
[ As Trump ]
COVID-19, of course,
is when a freshman goes
off to COVID
and they gain weight,
sometimes as much as 19 pounds.
The COVID-19, if you will.
I mean, why do you think they
call it the 2020 election?
Do you think you need
perfect eyesight to vote?
Of course, as always,
when he says "some people,"
he means himself.
That's his trademark way
of admitting
he doesn't know something.
As soon as someone
explains to him
what the 19 stands for,
you can be sure
he'll say something like,
"People don't know this,
but the 19 stands for the year
it was discovered.
That's something most people
just found out very recently
and not something they were told
multiple times, but they forgot
because they don't really
listen at meetings."
Now that he's overseen one
of the most catastrophic periods
in American history,
from a pandemic he ignored
to an economic crash
he has no interest in stopping,
this is all Trump has left,
doubling down
on explicit racism.
He and his allies on the right
have very few tricks left
in their reelection bag.
They've apparently settled
on a strategy
of racist fearmongering
about Black Lives Matter
protests,
undermining the integrity
of the election itself,
and assuring you that
the president's right arm
is strong enough
to hold a glass of water.
Normally, when someone's
eager to show you
they can hold a cup
on their own,
that cup has a Minion on it.
At this moment,
states like Arizona and Texas
are experiencing
record-setting COVID spikes
and Americans are campin' out
for hours in the heat
to apply for unemployment.
You'd think viewers tuning
into the news
would wanna hear some words
of assurance
about those crises
from the president.
Instead, Fox News chose to run
with this very real headline
from Trump's rally in Tulsa...
Wow, you guys are --
guys are doing some grade A
journalism over there.
It reminds me
of that famous headline
the day after the
Gettysburg Address...
They are really scrapin'
the bottom of the barrel.
It just goes to show you
how desperate they are
and how intellectually bankrupt
the conservative movement
has become.
They can't celebrate
any policy successes
because they don't have any
and they can't tell you
how great things are
because things are horrible.
The best they can do is brag
about the fact
that the president's motor
skills are still intact.
They're talking about him
like he just emerged
from a decade-long coma.
I can't wait for their
primetime special...
This is all they have left.
When they're not
enthusiastically
cheering the president
for successfully
lifting a glass to his lips,
the way you'd reward a dog
for learning how
to shake your hand,
they're trying to scare the crap
out of their audience
with racist fearmongering
about the
Black Lives Matter protests.
Here, for example,
is Rudy Giuliani on Fox,
claiming Black Lives Matter
was literally coming
to take your house away.
-Black Lives Matter,
the Communists,
and their allies
are executing a plan
they wrote about four,
five years ago.
Just go back and read
what they wrote
in the manifestos
that they wrote,
including "Black Lives Matter."
They wanna destroy
our government,
they wanna do away with our
system of courts.
and they want to take
your property away
and give it to other people.
This is an anarchist --
organized anarchists supported
with a lot of money.
People who say they're favorable
to Black Lives Matter?
Black Lives Matter wants to come
and take your house
away from you.
-[ As Giuliani ]
That's what happened to me!
They took my house away
and I've been sleeping
in the reptile wing of the
Natural History Museum.
No one notices me.
Besides, we all know that,
if anyone is gonna
take your house away,
it's Tom Selleck.
Oh, sure.
He says reverse mortgages
aren't a trick
to take away your house,
but if that were true, why would
he keep bringing it up?
That's like saying,
"Have some of the milkshake.
It's not poison.
I've told you the milkshake
isn't poison, haven't I?
Good.
Now, drink your milkshake.
It's not poison."
I got eyes on you, Selleck.
Just a side note here,
but, Rudy,
please stop saying you're
from New York City.
It's embarrassing
to the rest of us.
Can't you just tell everyone
you used to be the mayor
of Del Boca Vista or something?
Hell, just make somethin' up.
Tell people you're
from a country where people
are just naturally born
without necks.
No-neck-istan.
Oo-ooh!
I think that might call
for another attic high-five.
Okay. Jesus.
When did you get so picky,
Attic High-Five?
This kind of racist
fearmongering
is so absurd and on the nose,
it's almost hard
to take seriously,
if it wasn't obviously
the Fox News strategy
for tryin'
to get Trump reelected.
Last night, for example,
states like Texas,
Arizona, and California
set new records
for coronavirus infections,
and the U.S. headed back
up the curve toward our peak
from a few months ago,
prompting the European Union
to consider a ban
on travelers
from the United States.
Here's what the president's
favorite propaganda channel
was talking about.
-Democratic politicians
don't fear the mob.
Notice that? Why?
Because they don't need to.
They control the mob.
The mob operates
with their permission.
These are their foot soldiers.
This is their militia.
-Breaking tonight, massive chaos
in America's cities.
It's ongoing.
-The main point that everyone
watching this tonight
needs to understand
really clearly --
Biden equals chaos.
-"Biden
equals chaos"?
I hate to tell you this,
but even your guy
calls him Sleepy Joe.
I mean, you can't
have it both ways.
I mean, right now, he might
as well just be running
for Lunesta spokesman.
Look, I know he's been
doin' campaign events,
but I never even know
about them
and, honestly, I prefer that.
I love this strategy.
If I had my way,
Biden's campaign slogan
would be...
And if you guys
are so anti-chaos,
maybe you haven't noticed
the current president
is Donald Trump.
And I know you guys desperately
wish that wasn't true,
because you much prefer
to spend your time
attacking Democrats
than having to do PR
for the Squinty Eye of Sauron
over here,
but that's the reality.
This is a sociopathic
political movement
concerned only with amassing
and maintaining power
and they've decided,
amid Trump's many failures,
to double down on crude,
bald-faced racism
as their only hope of winning.
They don't actually
wanna govern. In fact...
-They wanna destroy
our government.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
As New York works hard
to reopen under phase 2,
remember that we're still
a city in crisis
and City Harvest
has been stepping up
to meet the increased need.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.